welcome mmm sorry into this video
oscarito thus Poland right yes or scurvy
touareg yeah there are so many titled
players never heard of him okay so
deform let's see what we get yeah
another Kings Indian i recently had
played the other but with the win and
this was a really interesting game so
that's some okay i know i've also tried
the Sun the capture some time yeah you
can take here Queen d2 there should be
six but I don't know this let's let's
play something else
this is some let's ambitious set up of
course but slow should be should be
playable I just want to continue with
nijah three castles and try to make
something out of my space advantage he
can play nighty for though and this is
some yeah okay this is probably a
completely ok for black yeah if Black
gets to exchange some some minor pieces
he's normally okay and destruction
hmm I'm a bit surprised by his log think
this is a very standard way to play yeah
I wonder if queen bee success may be a
threat yeah yeah maybe attacking be tool
and I want to play be 3fe place Quinn be
six until the special discern slightly
slightly annoying peace night h 2 f 3
years a very unnatural normal would be
Bishop to d3 but he can take f 3 which I
don't really want destroying my my pawn
structure our weight if you place okay
yeah i don't i don't really see a great
way forward tim bishop here i need to
get rid of this piece I really I really
do okay let's do this first maybe Bishop
d1 rookie three Rock fe1 something like
that it's not really great yeah black
has a very comfortable position one
thing though he is he is really spending
enormous amount of time I mean I'm slow
but he's even even a bit a bit slower it
seems ok obviously this rookie three
idea is not on so probably just Bishop
to d3 and are maybe night h2 this has
gained a bit in and strength as Nyjah
for wood to check the Queen at the age
six spawn yeah maybe yeah night h2 it's
a bit more has a bit more bite now all
this is yeah relatively speaking it's
not really dangerous for black wow he's
really taking enormous amount of time
well I mean this is really crazy I mean
I do i do the same stuff sometimes but
ok wants to go be five ok Knight g4 as
mentioned it may be sometimes in this
type of position you can play something
like G form H f3 + g for now where does
he put the bishop on these three maybe
mmm no 2g for this also d6 hanging
if I kept John slits it's a dusty six
hanging but what about my rook cm this
is really stupid look at e3 is playing
Bishop d4 right and then Bishop Bishop
to 2d three at the end that's that's
really bad so I'm losing in exchange
anyway I guess that's weird I want to
control II one so Knight f3
maybe I can at the end take on b5 and
take on b5 that's that's a pretty good
pin ah this is the rook yeah that was a
bad game black resins he really I'll
play me but two are so slow that he
blundered at the end I mean out place
maybe a bit of a strong word and I'm not
sure about this position it's it's still
complicated and this Bishop is also a
sort of liability maybe the problem is
the capture I guess this is the problem
I only now realized that I don't really
have squares if i go here Bishop d3 it's
winning the exchange and never go here
Bishop g4 is going to win the exchange
okay I came go to g3 but this I didn't
consider at all and it's not clear that
it is a bit more freely where is this
going I mean those two bishops are
really strong yeah so I gave up the
exchange and okay why why it is just
clear diversity I'm probably losing it's
not it's not so that such an easy task
technically and yet it's even even
debatable if this is good anymore what
to see playing now yeah the components
to play a five this is already not easy
I mean F F I have a pond and then the
two bishops Bishop c7 maybe be 66
minutes I don't know it's not it's not
so easy it's not so easy but ok yet he
had spent so much time that he blundered
blundered the rupiah lucky wind really
thanks for watching